a new statement there from msghani what
can we make of that
i think the statement from nazareth
ghani there probably raises uh two main
issues one is sort of technical and to
do with process and the other is to do
with um culture i think on the technical
side
it clearly uh sets out i think what
we've been reporting this morning and
what guests we'd had on um people that
had served say in the in the
conservative muslim forum have been
telling us
that there was really a lack of faith
that the actual disciplinary processes
the complaints processes that were
available to pursue issues like this so
that would have been the complaints
process that conservative party
headquarters would have run really
didn't have the confidence
of
nusgarni that it was
robust enough to deal with the
seriousness of the accusations that she
was making and clearly she felt
that it was not appropriate
for
the party to be essentially
investigating something that a
government minister um she said um had
uh told her
the second point i think that comes out
of that statement from miss ghani um is
about how complaints of this type are
treated within government
and whether um the government can fully
understand all the people that these
complaints are made to can fully
understand uh the hurt really that is
caused to someone of muslim faith when
they are essentially
told as nazgani alleges
that that is a reason
for her not progressing within her
career because ghani is essentially
saying that yes the prime minister did
meet with her yes he did invite her to
pursue this formal complaints process
but in her view he didn't believe that
the reaction from the prime minister and
the reaction from the government matched
the seriousness of what she was saying
and the impact that it had had on her
professionally um and personally now
what of course we've heard from downing
street and also from um mark spencer the
chief whip who is alleged to have made
these comments they have all said that
there is a zero tolerance approach
towards islamophobia within the
conservative party uh but they have also
said that it should be for the official
conservative party
complaints channel to deal with
accusations like this so i think nusgani
would say that that proves a point that
this isn't being taken
seriously enough
what we have also seen today that i
think is interesting
is the reaction that we've had in the
last 24 hours after this story broke in
the sunday times from cabinet ministers
and also from senior mps now late last
night when um the response was
officially coming in from the government
whips office that essentially was a
blanket denial and said that nurse
garnish needed to make a complaint if
there was going to be an investigation
and until she did that there wouldn't be
an inquiry nadim zahawi the education
secretary was tweeting that he thought
there now should be an investigation we
have also got quite a strongly worded
tweet given his position within the
cabinet from the health secretary
sanchez javid
today he has said nusgani is a friend
and a credit to the conservative party
this is a very serious matter which
needs a proper investigation i would
strongly support her in making a formal
complaint
she must be heard so sanji javid saying
essentially the onus is on nusgani to
make that complaint but i think when you
contrast what he has said there to the
quite robust denial from his ministerial
colleague mark spencer in a series of
late night tweets last night and then
you throw into the mix what the
education secretary said it's hard not
to see a degree of cabinet fracturing
over this now it would be easy to i
think dismiss that or not dismiss it but
to put that down to the seriousness of
these accusations if it wasn't for other
issues such as national insurance and
tax rises covert restrictions where we
have seen senior members we know about
senior members of boris johnson's team
beginning to push back
against the prime minister and express
their opinions a bit more
fervently we have also seen i think
arguments breaking out further down
government ranks and within the party
that i think at a time of stability in
government may well have been closed
down by the prime minister that are now
not being closed down and i think you
put all that together and when you speak
to mps that are skeptical about the
future of boris johnson they say that
this is what gives them um
their uh evidence if you like for boris
johnson not being able to survive impost
for much longer because they say the
instability the ripples that have
essentially been sent out by the
partygate um scandal and the impact that
has had on his authority sort of
draining authority from him
means that the process of governing is
becoming a lot more bumpy than it was so
when you're faced with really really
important and serious issues like the
one that nurse ghani has raised like
we'll face in april when it comes to
national insurance tax rises or energy
rises the authority that the prime
minister should have to sort of carry
his party and his administration with
him starts to go and i think what
skeptical rebel mps will say is that
when that's gone it's difficult to get
back and the only solution really is to
change the person at the top